[Enrico Giusti, Curator, Garden of Archimedes] Eratosthenes was the first to measure the diameter of the earth.
He used astronomical techniques
to perform this task.
The idea was that, in Summer Solstice,
the sun was vertical on Syene,
but it's more angled in Alexandria.
And Eratosthenes measured the distance between Syene and Alexandria,
and, from this and from the measure of the angles,
was able to deduce the angle
between the two cities
and, therefore, the radius of the earth.
The sun is vertical
on the Summer Solstice,
because Syene is on the Tropic,
so you have no shadow.
Actually, Eratosthenes noticed that, from the bottom of a pit,
you could see the sun exactly
vertical on your head.
So, for this calculation,
Eratosthenes used only a little trigonometry, and this was all.